the idea of the film which was which is
really different was to allow Kurt to
tell the story of his life through his
own through the best way he could which
is his heart because with Kurt Cobain
I've never encountered anyone like this
before I mean we all know artists who do
Moulton things like I know these guys
I'll put you know they do sound design
and they play in sermons in photography
and went up occurred you know worked in
equal parts in oral traditions and
visual traditions so he did you know he
was doing audio collage and film score
and of course the music that the Nirvana
music which was his greatest artistic
output and then visually was doing the
super 8 films and he was doing the
paintings and the drawings and so in a
way the film was intended to be an aural
visual sort of autobiography of his life
that I don't think anyone else could
have I just don't know any other artists
who work so expressly in those things
it's not that he's Picasso with his art
and I think that's one of the things
that's actually great is that's very
belated
you know the doodling that he does is
all stuff that we probably didn't were
kids now in that eight-year period from
from when you first talked to Courtney
about it at what point did you have
access to material and sort of have you
were able to suddenly see what you had
to work with and begin to be able to
shape that right that was in 2002 early
2013 we finally were given the keys to
the storage facility and and you know at
that point I'd been thinking about the
film for five years so in my mind this
storage facility was gonna look like the
end of Raiders of the Lost Ark or
Citizen Kane and it was gonna be this
vast warehouse of all the amazing stuff
and you know as you may imagine if you
put storage facility there little
innocuous and as a industrial lighting
and industrial carpet and there were I
walked in this frame and there were some
paintings around on the walls and then
there were about twelve boxes in the
middle and it was it was visually quite
underwhelming and but it goes to show
you that it was it's quiet quality
not quantity because what I didn't know
at that moment was one of those boxes
was gonna contain 107 cassettes
featuring 200 hours of
never-before-heard audio and Kurt would
record everything so like the scene in
the movie where he goes stands for the
phone and he says no she's not here I
mean all that stuff he would just he
would record himself when he was
watching television I mean it is really
crazy like he would just hit playing
record and he would write a song or he'd
cook or he'd do whatever and he did the
he would also do things where he'd write
in his journal and then record the
journal mm-hm
you know and so the story he tells of
losing his virginity to me is just it's
a it's a piece of art it's a performed
he wrote it and then he performed it and
he did several takes on it so again it's
another form of expression for him you
know if the greatest tribute the one can
do - for Kurt Cobain is to make an
honest movie because that's part of why
Kurt resonates with people is because he
brought a lot of so much honesty and
integrity to his work and I think as a
result of us taking this unflinching
look that the audiences I've been
exposed to are not turned off by carpet
actually I think it's almost more
endearing by the end and you know what
what I'd like to say is that we weren't
trying to tear him down and we weren't
trying to put him on a pedestal
we were just simply trying to look him
in the eye and at the end of the day I
think when you strip away the layers of
Mythology the man is born tearing than
the myth how do you approach adapting
Kurt's music for the film in a way that
will more make it work
dramatically for the film's sake but
also feel like it's true to him as a
composer that was actually one of the
great challenges but I mean it's a great
role to be cast in it as a composer I
mean I usually spend a lot of time
torturing myself in a room trying to
find out what the musical language of
the character and the stories are trying
to create themes and this one Bret
rightfully said you know this is Kurt
we're all occurred there's not an
original music here by you and if this
is going to be your adaptations of his
body of work and what an amazing iconic
body of work
so brad had the ideas really inspired
actually to treat particularly the first
half of the film to find arrangements
for some of these songs that were quite
dreamlike and almost childlike innocent
I called them ice cream truck versions
and that was just a joy to really to
explore those songs from a completely
different different level Brett and I
have talked about this before we don't
really sort of see it as well where that
word the documentary guys and these are
the dramatic guys you know we're telling
stories he said to me kids taste and
pictures in Opera like absolutely
understood what he meant to me it's
you're using music to deepen the story
get inside the characters heads there's
not a line that I I consider and I you
know we do it that way that the
difference in this film was just to be
using someone else's music I mean Brett
and I had this process where we'd be
listening to things and he would say
well you know what would this you know
how would this live we in the Curt realm
like how does this I think he did it
with all his departments and it was an
interesting acid test to put things to
because we could say well then well is
that the young Kurt we're thinking about
or is it Kurt as he would be now and you
know are these interesting and different
arrangements of his music how you know
how does it still channel him somehow
and it it was fascinating really and
then there was some times when Brett
would come in and he would say you know
the flutes not gonna fly with Kurt like
that's just not it's not a Kurt thing
and and you know and there are other
instruments of Brett now use all the
time where he just went yeah I can fly
with Kurt so there was there was a we
had to find that that space there one of
the greatest things that Cameron and I
like about working with Brett the number
one rule is there are no rules and you
know doing all these films that I've
done and that Cameron's worked on
there's a certain foundation and a
tradition to an approach of a soundtrack
that in this documentary world we're not
quite as restrained and took liberties
with treating sound processing sound
panning sound that you don't really get
to do in a lot of traditional movies and
so that was challenging and fun
for us and as Jeff said when we started
this Brett said look I don't want to
hear your sound design I don't
necessarily hear you're mixing the way
you do it I don't want to hear his score
that he'd done I want us to all try to
be and it we had to kind of wrap our
heads around it a little bit because how
do you do that I want you to think you
know Kurt was really into audio and and
I didn't know that you know I found out
doing this documentary how much playing
around he did and that sort of was a
little inspiration let's let's try
delays on this and let's pan this and
let's pitch that or whatever it was I
felt we could do that and most of the
time Brett was receptive to it you know
we might go a little too far but we we
were permitted to do that and that's one
of the fun things for me it was critical
to to embrace Kurt in all of his sound
design he had discovered and used those
pieces to to create other bits and
essentially find the emotion for each
bit and attach sound to to the emotional
the bed of of each scene and I never
lose sight of Kurt and Brett was right
there to point out when he was present
and if he was slipping away and we
reeled us back in it was uh it was quite
a journey